two degrees is the target for limiting
the global temperature increase
but if greenhouse gas emissions were
halted now temperatures would still rise
by up to 1 degrees Celsius 6000 years
ago
temperatures were at this level and
America's Midwest was a desert in this
future mountains lose their glaciers and
rivers vanish the Indian subcontinent
fighting for survival a single degree
temperature increase could eliminate
freshwater from 1/3 of the planet within
85 years warming at the poles happens
faster than the global average 40
percent of Arctic sea ice has
disappeared in the last 30 years while
ice reflects heat oceans absorb it so as
ice melts the process becomes
self-reinforcing more ocean surface
means more heat absorbed which raises
temperatures making the ice less likely
to reform mountainous regions are at
greater risk of landslides as the
permafrost which held them together for
thousands of years melts away low-lying
countries like the Maldives are
submerged as sea levels rise and
countries already hit by hurricanes face
even greater storms at a 2 degree rise
people begin to die in what are now
considered normal summers in 2003 with
temperatures 2.3 degrees above average
52 thousand people died across Europe
plant growth slows down then stops
plants don't absorb carbon dioxide as
efficiently instead emitting it the
extra carbon sees global warming spiral
out of control 125,000 years ago when
temperatures were 2 degrees higher sea
levels were up by 6 meters today that
extra water makes up our polar ice which
is melting by the year 2100 sea levels
could rise by a metre displacing 10% of
the world's population in this two
degree future ecosystems across the
globe collapse as species migrate and
fall out of sync 1/3 of all life on
Earth faces extinction scientists say we
can still avoid a 2-degree rise if we
limit our carbon
- no more than 2.9 trillion tons we've
already used one point nine trillion
tons we have one trillion left to use
between now and forever
at the current rate we'll use it in just
21 years